[Music]
excuse
you
yes
[Music]
rid of the
bottle I'm
[Music]
on
I get something huh you want get
something
[Music]
yeah
get a wig too
[Music]
yeah
thank
you
[Music]
like the white one huh I like the
white
what else you want H what else you
[Music]
want thank
you
[Music]
got this one
too yeah I gra that thank
you anything else
[Music]
got
can we see
that the
B which one that the f
one
top no underneath that one yeah the
purse yeah here a
15 it has the Su scrap in there
[Music]
okay
so see thank you thank you very much
[Music]
to the right to the right I want to go
that one let's go the same story went
before here you want to go here here go
[Music]
ahead match is your purse huh match is
your purse
yeah
[Music]
I feel
like
[Music]
right
it's your kind of
story
[Music]
see it you can call me in a SE please
follow the
[Music]
like that purple skirt and the pink fur
I'm sorry that purple skirt and the pink
fur Okay excuse me look at the the
purple
skirt and then the the pink uh fur
yeah what size what size
Rebecca what size oh
far only have medium on the SC only a
medium only a
medium being so blow
[Music]
what color and
what got
yeah I think that's going to be
it what's the name of your store car J
what is it
Jaz oh c Jazz C J C JZ M
okay you're here on Santi alley
yeah
big sorry you got a
[Music]
big
shoes terrify what's
that
sorry want
shoes
[Music]
n
not
[Music]
this
Crossing you don't want
shoes right now
fine you got those Crocs in the
car
you're going to be styling tomorrow
yeah
yeah we'll get you another save
[Music]
yeah glad you ate yeah I think a good
night of sleep will be really good for
you yes
[Music]
yes
fishing the guy on meth one
shoe dancing
put his hand on his
[Music]
junk
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
so what I'd suggest is get a good night
of sleep stay in the room for a change
stay in the room tomorrow morning I'll
come down we'll have a talk with the
immigration attorney uhuh and uh we get
you shaved get you all cleaned up take a
good shower
you'll be a you'll be a new girl
yeah all the sirens you hear in the
videos this is where they come
from sometimes it's the comps but most
of the time it's the fire department
have
paramedics
you're going to be okay I
know just not
tonight
see yeah
sure look at you see you can be
responsible definitely we had a 10:00
appointment to talk with the immigration
attorney
to help you with your immigration
problems and
you stayed
clean you woke up on time dressed ready
to go right on time I'm so impressed
thanks how are you doing oh I love your
outfit thanks your hair matches your ice
yeah I know it does and your outfit
matches my
background definitely
does when's the last time you
smoked a day ago yeah
yes you
slept I know it's kind
of it's trying to relax I guess I don't
know
you look great
thanks would you like to uh have a phone
call to talk about your immigration
issues oh my
go This Woman's name is
Carla and I will call her number right
now
hello hey Carla this is Mark L hey Mark
how are you I'm great how are you good
good guess who is sitting in front of me
no way sober well-dressed on time
everything unbelievable oh my gosh know
speaker I'm going to give you the phone
to Rebecca right give the phone to
Rebecca right now thanks oh amazing
amazing this is Carla hi Rebecca hi can
you hear me yeah I can hear you how are
you I'm all right how are you good
listen I'm so excited that I'm talking
to you so thank you for showing up thank
you so did Mark tell you who I am and
why I want to talk to
you I mean briefly
H so let let me tell you who I am and
then you can ask me some questions okay
yeah so
watch channel for months absolutely
enthralled with you right I noticed in
your videos that
you and in one of the videos you were
worried about being deported because you
didn't fall some
papers so yeah I'm yeah I'm an
immigration attorney okay so I sent mark
an email and was saying hey maybe if
Rebecca can talk to me we can maybe get
the ball rolling or figure out how I can
help you because I feel like if you had
this taken care of it would be a big
relief for you um and you wouldn't have
to worry about that anymore yeah yeah so
but in order for me to even do that
you'd have to be okay with giving me
permission to do that first of all and
you'd have to give Mark permission to
kind of act you know between us so it'
be the three of us but also you'd have
to be okay with giving me a lot of your
personal
information um I suppose
um yeah and if I ask you something and
you don't want to answer me just say
next okay because I only want you to
share with me what you're comfortable
with but I also want you to know
everything you tell me is confidential
okay because I am a lawyer I am an
attorney so I can't publicize you know
anything that you tell me or share it
other than what you give me permission
to of course okay so do you want to ask
me any questions or do you just want me
to start asking you some I mean you can
just go ahead I guess okay so the the
first thing that I need to know is when
you actually came to the United
States
um it must have been maybe
like I think like maybe like 5 years ago
maybe
okay so maybe
2018 yeah
maybe okay and how did you get get to
the United
States so um I basically came here on a
plane and
okay I guess I
I I uh overstay on my tourist
visa okay so you had a tourist visa yeah
was was this your first time ever come
to the United States no I've I've been
here before like a few times a few times
before yeah was it on that same Visa or
did you have a different Visa before
um different one but same um but same
category yeah
okay and then do you remember what city
you flew
into
um yes so I came in I I
will I guess
[Applause]
um
sorry it was
did you fly into Miami or maybe New York
um I guess New York New York yeah
where'd you fly from from Cairo
yeah
okay which did Egypt issue your
passport um I suppose
um
hello that's okay I'll wait on
you did Egypt issue you the passport
yeah
okay so the reason I'm asking that
Rebecca is because the first step in
sorting out your immigration would we
have to get your immigration records
yeah okay so and and I'm gonna I don't
think you have any of these old
documents your old passport or any of
that stuff I don't have any of that
stuff
now well that but that's okay because we
can request all of those records from
the government
okay okay so another part of that is I'd
have to know the name that you used when
you entered the name that was on your
[Applause]
Visa
um
um backa with we were just trying to
help you I know
um so listen if you're not if you're not
comfortable telling me is it okay that
Mark just tells me later if he knows um
which I
do I suppose
um okay we can we can do it that way
okay and then the the one last question
I have about any of this is oh your
birthday I would need to know your
birthday
um August
4 yeah what year
um um I got
some
um
at 97 yeah I got
some so so August 4 of 97
yeah August 497 thank
you so here's what I want to do for you
Rebecca yeah okay because I want to I
want to help you get this
sorted is I have to draft some paper
okay part of that is we have to have an
address for you which we're going to use
as my Law Office okay yeah so that way
all of your records will be sent to me
and then I can get them to Mark to make
sure everything's secure yeah okay the
second thing is when I draft these
papers I need you to sign them okay okay
so I can I can get them tomorrow by this
afternoon so we'll need you to hang
around as long as you can just to sign
some papers
okay okay one once I get it back and I
can I can file for your records it does
take months before we get a response
okay so it's not going to be
quick but I can send confirmation that
it's processing yeah
okay okay okay because there there's
there's ways that we'll be able to help
you so that you don't have
to keep living how you how you've been
living okay and you can get some
help
okay so I'm I'm happy to do this for you
I'm going to do it you know with Mark's
help of course but we just will need you
to stay around the sign
okay Carla thank you very much
it's very sweet of you to offer this
help thank you thank you so much yeah so
listen than listen if you think of any
questions you want to ask me about about
your immigration stuff or just who I am
or anything you let me know I'm happy to
talk to you anytime I'm
sure okay okay all right thank you thank
you Rebecca to Mark real quick sure car
you're an angel thank Youk you so I'm
gonna send you an
email just to follow up because I do
need Rebecca's name that was
used Rebecca's given name was Ishmael i
s h m without an h no h yeah i s m a e l
a i l a i l so i s m a i l and the last
name is Saudi s e o u d i s e o u d i
s e o d i s e o u d i okay u d i okay
got it is i s m a i
l sod s e o u d
i okay August August August
4th
quick wasn Inyo were you born in
Cyro um
I got some you don't remember I know
it's all
complicated he say it's
complicated yeah because there's a lot
of
um what what we would call Incorporated
parts and it all gets kind of pushed
into the big bigger cities so we'll
we'll start with CYO and go from
there excellent
just call me anytime Carla and we'll
figure we'll try to get the answers you
need you're give give me a couple hours
I'll get this stuff drafted I'll send it
over to you in an email and and I print
it out and yeah yeah you I what I'll do
is I'll make two attachments one
complete attachment and then an
attachment which just has the pages that
need the signature okay then you'll
print those Rebecca will sign them but
sign them mail and then get those back
to me and then I can do the filing
perfect sounds easy thanks and then Hey
listen once we get those back then we
can go from there to figure out you know
how to how to get this sorted it on the
right track beautiful so perfect all
right thanks M you're amazing thank you
so much car all byee you're welcome
bye what do you think of
that
yeah that's was really sweet of if you
guys really help me out I guess yes it
would that's a big problem yeah
and could lead to some other solutions
that might help you as
well people love
you so do
[Music]
I we're going to help you out thank
you what are you going to do
today I know I ask was the room okay
yeah it was it was
really yeah thank you do you want it for
a few more nights
maybe I'll get it for you permanently if
you
want I don't know
honestly but what was the most difficult
part of that conversation with
Carla
um is it is it difficult for you to
accept something good that might help
you that might put your life on
[Music]
try no I
just but what was difficult called about
it I don't know
um how's your ear it's it's it's feeling
a little better I guess do you want to
go see a
doctor maybe I don't know
um
let me work on getting a room and we'll
figure out what else we can do to help
you out all right thanks all
right
that